die leute haben immer mehr angst auch um
ihren job also tatsächlich merken wir da
gibt es viele job fragen die hier auf
klopfen die werden wir natürlich auch in
den nächsten sendungen auch nochmal
thematisieren wie sehen sie das gerade
in ihrem beratungsalltag also ist quasi
tägliche beratung da gibt es immer so
ein bisschen um die frage wie können wir
diese krise bewältigen aus sicht der
unternehmer und natürlich auch
betroffene arbeitnehmer in kurzarbeit
sind oder waren
und naja da stellt sich natürlich die
frage kann uns das retten ja oder nein
oder müssen wir sogar noch einen schritt
weiter gehen und das hängt so ein
bisschen von der entwicklung ab und
viele unternehmer beschweren sich
natürlich darüber dass es trotzdem nicht
so richtig voran geht nicht so richtig
der ja der konsum nicht so wieder
gestartet wird und da hoffen ja jetzt
alle auch die unternehmer hoffen
natürlich alle auf diesen push effekt
durch die reduzierung der mehrwertsteuer
und da müssen wir mal sehen was sich
daraus ergibt ob tatsächlich diese
positiven erfolge eintreten und das die
perfekte überleitung auch zu unserem
ersten zuschauer fall zugeschaltet ist
als berthold d klar
hallo herr de klar hallo herr de klar
erzählen sie uns mal sie haben jetzt ein
bisschen geldnot waren bei mcdonalds
oder sind bei mcdonald's aber dort jetzt
beurlaubt weil wahrscheinlich das
restaurant geschlossen ist wie stellt
sich die lage aus ihrer sicht da ja das
problem ist einfach so meine frau mein
ich bekommen erwerbsminderungsrente als
wenn da treffen wir noch ein 450 euro
job ausüben und mein mcdonald's
beziehungsweise am airport hamburg hat
leider noch zu und deswegen bin ich
erstmal in den urlaub das heißt ich
bekomme überhaupt kein geld kein
kurzarbeitergeld
wir haben auch schon bei sämtlichen
ämtern versucht zuschüsse zu bekommen
worden überall abgelehnt weil wir das
problem haben dass die
erwerbsminderungsrente kommen so wir
haben jetzt zu wenig geld und wissen
eigentlich gar nicht weiter es werden
immer von kurzarbeiter gesprengt
kurzarbeitergeld gesprochen und hier
hilfe da hilfe aber ich fühle mich
eigentlich vollkommen stich gelassen
da wollen wir doch mal an kämpften zu
dem thema befragen und wie stellt sich
die situation aus ihrer sicht dar
also wir haben hier
die möglichkeit des zahlungsaufschub im
zusammenhang mit der miete auch mit den
krediten das kann man in anspruch nehmen
das ist allerdings auch ein bisschen
kritisch weil diese zahlungsaufschub
führt ja nur dazu da sich zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt zahlen muss dann eben
nicht jetzt also das ist jetzt eine
reduzierung der ausgaben
aber das läuft natürlich auf der anderen
seite auch die schulden auf deshalb
würde ich in solchen fällen immer
unbedingt dazu raten mit den
vertragspartnern mit denen man eher zu
tun hat dass man mit denen vernünftig
spricht und vielleicht auch eine
regelung erzielt dass man eine
mietkürzung irgendwie auch herbeiführen
kann
das ist natürlich ist das nicht populär
bei den vermietern aber ein guter mieter
hat es immer relativ vielleicht mit dem
vermieter auch im gespräch zu bleiben
das ist sicherlich eine möglichkeit
ansonsten wie gesagt diesen
zahlungsaufschub man kann im moment ja
nicht gekündigt werden wenn wir die neat
miete nicht bezahlt das liegt ja in
diesen stunden gesetz will ich dass man
im zusammenhang mit den mieten und was
so diese verbraucherkredite anbelangt
damals ähnlich da bitte kontakt
aufnehmen mit der bank die zahlung
bleibt zwar aber man hat zumindest einen
aufschub und auf der haben seite ist es
natürlich etwas schwer da jetzt etwas zu
machen da besteht im grunde genommen nur
die möglichkeit jetzt zu versuchen auf
einer branche sich aufzusatteln wo jetzt
leute gesucht werden das sind natürlich
die transportunternehmen das sind
zuzustellen unternehmen und das sind so
vor ort unternehmen da wird was gesucht
vielleicht kann man da irgendwie ja
vorübergehend eine arbeitsstelle finden